sur public sénat bonjour à tous merci de
nous retrouver sur public sénat pour une
journée spéciale à l'occasion de la
reprise de la session parlementaire une
session extraordinaire qui va donc se
tenir tout au long du mois de juillet
alors ce matin je vous propose deux
temps forts nous sommes ensemble de
10h30 à 13h à commencer donc par la
lecture du discours de politique
générale elle a été lue hier aux
sénateurs par le numéro deux du
gouvernement laurent fabius
le ministre des affaires étrangères qui
s'est fait vous allez voir un peu
chahuté par les sénateurs de droite
c'est inhabituel dans la haute assemblée
qui d'habitude est connu pour une
ambiance plus feutrée et puis de 11h30 à
13h vous pourrez suivre en direct
l'audition de didier migaud le président
de la cour des comptes est entendu par
la commission des finances du sénat
deux jours après la remise de son no dit
au premier ministre alors tout de suite
donc direction en les mystiques pour un
retour sur une séance particulièrement
agitée bonne matinée à tous
la séance est ouverte le procès verbal
de la séance du 6 mars a été distribué
il n'ya pas d'observation le procès
verbal est adoptée les chers collègues
en application des articles 29 et 30 de
la constitution
la session extraordinaire 2011 2012 est
ouverte
j'ai reçu de monsieur le premier
ministre communication du décret de
monsieur le président de la république
en date du 27 juin 2012 portant
convocation du parlement en session
extraordinaire à compter du 3 juillet
ce décret vous a été adressé le 28 juin
dernier acte est donnée de cette
communication afin de respecter le
rythme de lecture par monsieur le
premier ministre de la déclaration de
politique générale devant l'assemblée
nationale je vais donner la parole
à monsieur laurent fabius je vous
donnerai lecture des conclusions de la
conférence des présidents qui s'est
réuni le 28 juin 2012 à l'issue de la
lecture de la déclaration de politique
générale du gouvernement
je sais d'ores et déjà que certains de
nos collègues souhaitent faire des
observations sur l'ordre du jour je vous
propose que ses prises de parole
interviennent à ce moment-là l'ordre du
jour appelle la lecture d'une
déclaration de politique générale du
gouvernement au nom du sénat vous me
permettrez de saluer chaleureusement la
présence au banc du gouvernement de
monsieur laurent fabius ministre des
affaires étrangères et des ministres qui
nous font l'honneur et aussi le plaisir
de leur présence je leur souhaite une
très cordiale bienvenue
chacun chacun ici comprendra que j'ai
une pensée particulière pour nos
collègues sénatrices et sénateurs qui
ont fait leur entrée au gouvernement
je suis très heureux de présider bien
sûr cette séance qui marque la reprise
des travaux du cdh a suspendu du moins
en séance publique
depuis le 6 mars dernier jeudi suspendu
en séance publique car nous avons vu
vous le savez tous nous avons eu à coeur
précisément de poursuivre nos travaux
dans les différentes instances de notre
assemblée
cette continuité et je crois la marque
du scénar institution permanente de la
république
en attendant le message particulier que
nous adressera de même sur le premier
ministre s'est donc animé de l'espoir de
répondre aux attentes de nos
compatriotes que nous allons désormais
monsieur le ministre
prendre connaissance de la déclaration
de politique générale prononcé en ce
moment même à l'assemblée nationale dans
monsieur le premier ministre
jean marc ayrault la parole est à
monsieur laurent fabius ministre des
affaires étrangères
le président l'a mené messieurs les
sénateurs je vais donc donner lecture
dans ce cas secondes du discours de
politique générale de monsieur premier
auparavant je voudrais vous dire
l'honneur que je ressentais à cette
tribune et vous confirmer que le
gouvernement est à disposition des
groupes de la majorité de l'opposition
dans les semaines qui viennent
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les parlementaires c'est
monsieur ayrault qui parle pour la
première fois depuis 26 ans je ne serais
pas assis parmi vous il y à quelques
instants lorsque je suis entré par la
porte de bronze j'ai pensé à tous ces
premiers ministres qu'ils ont franchi
avant moi à d'autres périodes confronter
à d'autres défis
je viens devant vous chargé d'une
mission particulière celle que m'a
confié le président de la république qui
a fixé notre cap conduire le
redressement de notre pays dans la
justice cet engagement a fait l'objet
d'un long débat démocratique et après
avoir élu le 6 mai françois hollande à
la tête de l'état les françaises et les
français ont choisi la cohérence
en donnant à la gauche une large
majorité parlementaire il me revient
l'honneur de vous soumettre la politique
d'un gouvernement entièrement mobilisé
pour le changement comportement pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de la
république autant de femmes que d'hommes
et portant l'exigence d'une autre
pratique des institutions ce
gouvernement
ali les talents de la jeunesse et de
l'expérience
il conjugue les parcours les histoires
et les cultures
il est aux couleurs de la france en vous
regardant j'observe aussi le changement
aux côtés de visages qui me sont si
familiers je découvre tant d'autres que
j'apprendrai à connaître à toutes et à
tous j'adresse mes plus sincères
félicitations parlementaires de la
majorité comme de l'opposition
vous détenez une part égale de la
souveraineté nationale
je sais que vous en serez digne à chacun
de faire preuve de courage et de
responsabilité dans une période qui
exige de chacun qu'il élève sa réflexion
son discours et ses propositions au
niveau d'une crise sans précédent et qui
menace de nous faire perdre ce que le
siècle passé nous a légué notre modèle
social et républicain
je suis venu aujourd'hui pour vous
appeler à travers vous appeler
l'ensemble de notre peuple à une
mobilisation car il n'est pas trop tard
pour agir
et pour réussir je suis ici pour vous
appeler à retrouver confiance dans notre
destin notre pays s'est affaiblie
économiquement il s'est dégradé
socialement il s'est divisée
politiquement il s'est abîmé moralement
la situation
la situation la france ce sont près de 3
millions de salariés qui ne retrouve pas
de travail ces femmes à qui n'est
proposé que des emplois à temps très
partiel ces jeunes pour qui l'emploi
pour qui l'entrée dans la vie active
s'apparente à un parcours d'obstacles
ces seniors qui se voit fermer toutes
les portes
alors qu'ils ont encore tante a apporté
ce sont ses plans sociaux opportunément
retardé et qui font courir le risque du
chômage à plusieurs dizaines de milliers
de familles supplémentaires entre 2007
et 2011 la dette publique a augmenté de
600 milliards d'euros cette dette
atteint aujourd'hui près de 1800
milliards d'euros soit 90 % de la
richesse produite par la france chaque
année
le poids de la dette est devenue
écrasant l'état verse ainsi près de 50
milliards d'euros par an à ses
créanciers
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs de
l'opposition si monsieur ayrault était
là et vous dirait un instant de patients
le poids de la dette est devenue
écrasant l'état verse ainsi près de 50
milliards d'euros par an à ses
créanciers
cette somme représente la première
dépense jusque devant le budget de
l'éducation nationale
elle est supérieure au budget de la
recherche de la justice et de la
sécurité réunis
c'est inacceptable la dette c'est moins
d'écoles moins de crèches ou moins
d'hôpitaux moins de transports publics
la dette c'est ce que nous léguons aux
générations futures si nous n'agissons
pas je suis de la génération qui a
grandi pendant les trente glorieuses
celle pour laquelle l'avenir était
naturellement synonyme de progrès je ne
veux pas être de la génération qui aura
reporter le poids d'une dette excessive
sur ses enfants et ses petits enfants
mon gouvernement sera sous la
responsabilité devant la jeunesse
la dette c'est enfin un enjeu
souveraineté une france endettée est une
france dépendantes dépendance vis-à-vis
des agences de notation dépendance
vis-à-vis des marchés financiers voilà
pourquoi je veux réduire notre
endettement public parce qu'il ne
saurait y avoir de redressement du pays
sans redressement de nos comptes publics
mais je ne suis pas venu l'ancien débat
sur l'héritage tant d'autres avant nous
ont ainsi préféré chercher dans le rejet
de leurs prédécesseurs
une approbation qu'il n'aurait pas
trouvé au simple énoncé de leur
politique que cette situation soit le
produit d'erreurs passées signifie aussi
que nos difficultés peuvent être
surmontées
cette situation est simplement notre
point de départ que le président la
république avait largement anticipé au
cours de sa campagne
nous pourrions utiliser la situation que
nous avons trouvé pour justifier des
renoncements et bien non nous ne
renonçons à rien cette majorité n'a pas
été élu pour trouver des excuses mais
des solutions
la mise en oeuvre de ces solutions qui
sont les engagements pris par le
président de la république passe d'abord
par l'exigence de vérité dans l'épreuve
trop souvent la préférence a été donnée
à l'habileté à la mystification voire à
la dérobade
je veux dire aux français la vérité je
veux leur dire ce que nous ferons je
veux qu'ils puissent être juge à chaque
instant les chemins que nous en foutons
je veux qu'ils puissent exercer leur
contrôle
sous l'éclairage que peuvent leur donner
la majorité comme l'opposition à cette
fin je tiendrai régulièrement informé
nos concitoyens à travers la
représentation nationale de l'action
conduite
la tentation existe d'exploiter les
peurs et les clins de stimuler les
égoïsmes d'user de tous les clivages qui
travaille la société aux fins de dévier
le débat public des sujets essentiels je
ne céderai pas je souhaite au contraire
que les françaises et les français
unissent leurs efforts et retrouve le
sens du combat commun les décisions qui
sont devant nous les intéresse au
premier chef
ce ne sont pas des débats réservé à une
élite c'est sous le regard de nos
concitoyens sous leurs arbitrages qui
s'exprime par le suffrage universel que
j'entends gouverner notre pays la
sauvegarde de notre modèle républicain
la pérennité de notre système social
le redressement économique pour l'emploi
voilà la finalité de notre action elle
s'apparente aujourd'hui à un combat nous
pouvons et nous devons l'emporter
la condition est la mobilisation et
l'engagement de tous le génie de la
france ce n'est pas la concentration
dans les mains de quelques-uns de notre
destin commun
gelly la france est d'avoir su justement
passer d'un système monarchique ou
autoritaire à l'association de tous à la
décision
le génie de la france c'est la
république comme vous j'aime la france
j'aime sa langue j'aime ces paysages
aime sa culture j'aime son histoire
j'aime les valeurs qui l'ont façonnée
j'aime son goût pour le débat
j'aime l'idée que la nation française
soit fondé sur le désir de lui
appartenir plus que sur la naissance
j'aime qu'elle puisse servir de modèle
en europe et dans le monde
car son message est universel j'aime
aussi notre cas pas
cité en certaines circonstances de notre
histoire à nous dépasser à mettre chacun
deux côtés ce qui nous divise pour nous
retrouver ensemble et faire la france
comme vous je suis un patriote l'enjeu
c'est aujourd'hui de savoir si nos
enfants pour ôter mais le même pays et
vivre avec le même bonheur
ils élever leurs enfants à leur tour en
ayant la volonté la fierté de leur
transmettre les mêmes valeurs
au premier rang de notre combat pour le
redressement j'appelle ces femmes et ces
hommes qui par leur savoir-faire leur
intelligence leur a créé de la richesse
des emplois de l'activité vous qui
produisent et vous qui disposez de la
capacité de décider vous qui dirigez
mobilisez-vous sans attendre et dès la
france en créant l'emploi en préservant
l'activité dans notre pays en relevant
le défi productif au dessus de l'argent
que l'on gagne il y à ce sentiment plus
grand plus fort celui que procure
l'estiment et la reconnaissance de ses
concitoyens je ne suis pas l'ennemi
l'argent mais je ne considère pas les
gens auxquels je parle en fonction de
leur patrimoine et de leurs revenus
je n'accepte pas d'entendre dénoncé une
fiscalité confiscatoire par ceux là même
qui s'autorise parfois des rémunérations
au delà de tout entendement
le patriotisme c'est servir son pays
c'est remplir ses devoirs après avoir
reçu tant de droit c'est rendre la
république ce qu'elle vous a donné le
patriotisme ce n'est pas fuir la france
pour les paradis fiscaux et laisser à
ceux qui restent le poids de l'effort
le patriotisme cela doit être la sphère
de tout c'est le tous à chaque niveau de
la société la mobilisation doit être
générale
elle ne concerne pas que le sommet de
l'édifice
chacun doit prendre sa part faire preuve
de patriotisme c'est ne pas menacer la
pérennité d'un système solidaire en le
détournant de son objectif qui est
d'assurer un filet de sécurité celles et
ceux qui ne trouvent pas de travail à
ceux qui sont en fin de droits aux
malades à tous les niveaux le
gouvernement se donnera les moyens de
lutter contre la fraude
et d'abord contre l'évasion fiscale dans
ce combat pour le redressement
nous avons besoin de tous les acteurs il
ne peut pas être la sphère du
gouvernement seul le changement ne se
décrète pas il ne se mesure pas au
nombre de lois votées il est un
mouvement qui n'inspire toute la société
un mouvement porté par tous les corps
intermédiaires collectivités locales
partenaires sociaux associations
organisations non gouvernementales le
maire de nantes
c'est que le changement passe par la
mise en mouvement de toute la société
il n'aurait jamais obtenu les mêmes
résultats s'ils ne s'étaient pas
constamment appuyé sur l'imagination la
créativité et le dynamisme de ses
concitoyens et de l'ensemble des acteurs
locaux
il est fini le temps des sommets
spectacle temps où la concertation
n'étaient conçus que pour donner
l'apparence du dialogue social à la
décision d'un seul
il est fini le temps où l'état imposer
ses décisions à des collectivités
territoriales qu'il considérait comme de
simples satellite chargé d'exécuter sa
volonté
nous ouvrons la porte à une évolution
profonde un bouleversement inédit je
demande à chacun d'en prendre la mesure
nous voulons donner toutes ses chances à
la démocratie est d'abord à la
démocratie sociale la réduction du
chômage et le développement l'emploi et
donc le développement de nos entreprises
doivent être une préoccupation partagée
je souhaite que la culture de l'accord
celles qui impliquent des contreparties
du donnant-donnant s'impose
organisations d'employeurs et de
salariés doivent prendre leurs
responsabilités
le gouvernement prendra aussi les
siennes cet état d'esprit nouveau s'est
déjà exprimée à travers l'organisation
d'une grande conférence sociale qui
s'ouvrira dans quelques jours les
travaux porteront sur sept sujets
majeurs l'emploi et particulièrement
l'emploi des jeunes la formation le
développement des compétences et la
sécurisation des parcours professionnels
les rémunérations et notamment les bas
salaires
l'égalité professionnelle femmes hommes
et la qualité de vie au travail
le redressement productif national
l'avenir de nos retraites et notre
protection sociale
enfin le rôle de nos services publics et
ses agents tout sera mis sur la table y
compris l'intégration des représentants
des salariés dans les conseils
d'administration des grandes entreprises
le dialogue social territorial au niveau
des bassins d'emploi l'information en
amont des représentants du personnel
rien ne sera tabou tout devrait être
posée si nous voulons parvenir à de
nouveaux équilibres dans un compromis à
bien des égards historique d'autres
concertation suivront dans le même
esprit sur les priorités du quinquennat
j'ouvrirai une consultation à sur la
refondation de l'école le 5 juillet
des assises de l'enseignement supérieur
et de la recherche préparons une loi de
programmation qui sera présenté au
parlement au début de l'année 2013
la conférence environnementale s'ouvrira
dès la rentrée pour préparer le grand
chantier de la transition énergétique et
de la biodiversité
enfin la démocratie locale sera
renforcée au travers d'un nouvel acte de
la décentralisation qui fera l'objet
d'une large consultation
je sais par expérience que les attentes
sont fortes et multiples on ne va jamais
assez vite lorsqu'il s'agit de corriger
la justice ou de protéger du souffrance
mais je sais surtout que les lois
bâclées ne sont jamais appliquées
je connais le temps que l'on perd à
force de vouloir en gagner je sais que
l'on ne combat pas l'inertie par
l'agitation la tentation de tout pouvoir
est d'aller vite d'imposer sa marque dès
les premières heures de tout réaliser en
100 jours comme si plus rien ne devait
être possible ensuite et bien le
président de la république comme moi
même nous voulons installer ce
changement dans la durée prendre le
temps d'écouter d'évaluer de décider de
faire partager
c'est la condition même du changement je
crois que les françaises et les français
veulent être traités en adulte je crois
à la possibilité de fédérer le pays
autour d'objectifs et d'un projet commun
les français ne nous ont pas donné un
mandat pour gouverner sans jours mais
cinq ans le redressement prendra du
temps mais nous surmonterons la crise et
nous retrouverons le progrès au cours du
quinquennat
deux phases se succéderont la première
sera celle des réformes de structure
j'entends par là la consolidation la
rénovation de tous les outils qui nous
permettront de renouer avec la
croissance la compétitivité et l'emploi
je pense à la réforme fiscale je pense
ce redressement productif
je pense à la priorité donnée à la
jeunesse
je pense à la nouvelle étape de la
décentralisation
je pense à la transition écologique et
énergétique
il faut donc prendre le temps de réussir
ses grandes réformes de structures pour
que viennent ensuite celui de tirer les
bénéfices de l'effort collectif
je n'ai pas l'obsession de la
comparaison avec le gouvernement
précédent mais je me demande à chacun de
mesurer la différence qui n'est pas
simplement une différence de style mais
de méthode
la première erreur
c'est de vouloir imposer d'en haut et
dans la précipitation
la deuxième c'est de vouloir opposer de
manière dogmatique justice et
compétitivité justice et efficacité
je crois que la justice n'est pas
seulement une exigence morale
je crois qu'elle est un facteur de
croissance je crois que ce qui est juste
est une motivation au travail
je crois que faire fonctionner des
services publics de qualité participe à
l'attractivité d'un territoire que la
productivité est directement liée à la
qualité des ingénieurs des techniciens
ou les ouvriers qui sortent de nos
écoles je crois qu'une fiscalité qui
valorise le travail plutôt que la rente
est un profond encouragement pour celles
et ceux qui prennent des risques
oui je crois que la justice est efficace
être juste c'est aussi reconnaître
l'apport des créateurs des innovateurs
des entrepreneurs je crois en l'esprit
d'initiative j'estime les chefs
d'entreprise et je les connais je salue
le rapport à notre économie
je ne les confonds pas avec quelques
parachutistes dorés ou avec des
spéculateurs sans scrupules
être juste c'est aussi ne pas
stigmatiser les chômeurs en leur faisant
porter la responsabilité de leur
infortune être juste c'est de pas
considérer chaque bénéficiaire du rsa
comme un fraudeur pennant ce potentiel
pourquoi ma fainéants la justice sur la
dent tout à la fois notre moyens et
notre but
la justice est également territoriales
elle doit s'exprimer sur les territoires
fragiles particulièrement les quartiers
défavorisés qui sont le lieu de
l'association sociale je n'oublie pas
non plus et millions de nos concitoyens
qui vivent aujourd'hui éloignés des
grands centres urbains les classes
populaires et les classes moyennes a
vite souvent ces villes que l'on
qualifie de pire urbaine ou dans les
zones rurales ce sont ces français qui
ont aujourd'hui les conditions de vie
souvent les plus durs à la précarité de
l'emploi s'ajoutent des temps de
transport à rallonge la désertification
médicale la fermeture des services
publics
je veux qu'à côté de l'effort marque est
nécessaire pour les banlieues l'état se
tourne aussi vers ces territoires que
souvent négligée et redéploie ses moyens
prioritairement en leur direction
dans le même esprit celui de l'égalité
entre tous les territoires qui font la
france
j'adresse le salut fraternel de toute la
nation à nos outre mer ou la faiblesse
des orientations mises en oeuvre au
cours du dernier quinquennat a pu passer
pour une forme de désintérêt voire de
désengagement de l'état la politique
gouvernementale s'y appliquera donc avec
force autour de trois priorités que sont
la jeunesse l'emploi et la lutte contre
la vie chère
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
le rétablissement des comptes publics
est un enjeu majeur
le président de la république a fixé les
priorités la jeunesse la sécurité la
justice
elles seront respectées sans pour autant
poser nos déficits et notre dette cela
exigera des choix dans tous les autres
secteurs
ces efforts devront des ports non pas
d'une règle mathématique aveugle et
absurde mais de l'évaluation des
politiques conduites et de leur
efficacité
c'est pourquoi j'ai demandé au ministre
de réaliser des économies sur leurs
dépenses fondée sur des propositions de
réformes qu'ils élaboreront eux mêmes et
qui permettront de faire gagner en
efficacité nos services publics
il s'agira d'un travail de fond mené en
concertation avec les agents de l'état
sur les missions et le fonctionnement
des services publics
j'ai lu ces derniers jours que le fait
de réserver les créations d'emplois
publics aux secteurs prioritaires devès
interpréter je cite comme un tournant de
la rigueur
je m'inscris en faux contre cette
affirmation les effectifs de l'état que
les trois stabilité globale alors que le
précédent gouvernement les détruisaient
massivement
l'ensemble de notre stratégie sera fixé
dans le cadre d'une loi de programmation
des dépenses publiques qui couvrira les
cinq années de cette législature
cette fois nous engagera sur un retour à
l'équilibré à l'horizon 2017
elle crache main en faisant la part des
efforts demandés à chacun et tu as
sécurité sociale et collectivités
locales
l'abs et messieurs les parlementaires la
maîtrise des dépenses est indispensable
mais elle ne sera pas suffisante de
nouvelles recettes fiscales seront
mobilisés la volonté de ce gouvernement
c'est de solliciter d'abord ce qui
jusqu'ici ont été exonérés de l'effort
collectif
ainsi dès demain le projet de loi de
finances rectificative tirera les
conclusions de l'audit indépendant
réalisé par la cour des comptes aux fins
de respecter l'engagement du président
de la république de réduire dès 2012 le
déficit public à 4 5% de la richesse
nationale
cet audit confirme les analyses faites
pendant la campagne présidentielle et
valide les mesures et orientations que
le gouvernement s'apprête à présenter au
parlement
le collectif budgétaire qui vous sera
soumis n'épuisera pas le sujet de la
réforme fiscale
mais il n'en constituera une première
étape
il reviendra sur l'allongement
incompréhensible de l'impôt de
solidarité sur la fortune et des droits
sur les grosses successions
il reviendra sur le bouclier fiscal
l'exonération des heures supplémentaires
dans les entreprises de 20 salariés qui
décourage la création de nouveaux
emplois et mettra à contribution les
grandes entreprises notamment bancaires
et pétrolières en revanche les classes
populaires et les classes moyennes
seront épargnées puisque sera abrogé la
hausse de la tva programmée pour octobre
par le précédent gouvernement
tandis que la tva sur le livre et le
spectacle vivant repassera à cinq et
demi pour cent la réforme fiscale se
poursuivra à l'automne dans le cadre du
projet de loi de finances pour 2013
l'impôt sur le revenu sera rendue plus
juste plus progressif et plus
compréhensible les niches fiscales
seront ainsi plafonner le taux
d'imposition réel des contribuables
aisés ne peut plus continuer d'être
inférieur à celui de la majorité des
français pour les plus riches
une nouvelle tranche d'imposition à 45 %
sera créé pour les revenus annuels
supérieurs à 1 million d'euros
une imposition exceptionnelle à 75 %
sera instauré les revenus du capital
seront imposées au même niveau que ceux
du travail
il n'est plus possible de tenir des
discours sur la valorisation du travail
et dans les faits de privilégier la
rente à moyen terme d'autres chantiers
seront ouverts avec toujours le même
souci de justice d'efficacité économique
et écologique maîtriser la dépense
publique trouver de nouvelles recettes
fiscales voilà le préalable au
redressement de notre pays
contrairement à ce qu'on a pu lire ou
entendre ces derniers jours le
gouvernement n'a pas besoin d'opérer un
tournant il n'y aura pas de tournant
nous avions anticipé pendant la campagne
la faiblesse de la croissance en 2012
estimé à 0 7% par le gouvernement
précédent
elle sera en réalité ce 0 3% pour 2013
la prudence et la sincérité de
conduisent anticiper une croissance de
l'ordre de 1,2 pour cent nous savions
que le budget 2012 comportait des
sous-évaluations de dépenses et des
estimations trop optimiste de recettes
la cour des comptes l'a confirmé ce que
nous pressentions la situation est
sérieuse elle n'est pas une surprise le
chemin du redressement budgétaire que
nous avions indiqué celui qui nous
emprunterons nous revendiquons le
sérieux et la responsabilité budgétaire
nous voulons la justice fiscale
j'appelle à l'effort national mais je
refuse l'austérité rien rien ne sera
possible si nous ne retrouvons pas la
croissance
ce combat se mène sur d'autres fronts un
front intérieur celui du redressement
productif
un front européen celui d'une
réorientation de la politique de l'union
le redressement productif doit passer
par la mobilisation de toutes les forces
de toutes les énergies de la france et
de tous les secteurs économiques les
services l'industrie l'agriculture et
l'industrie agroalimentaire l'économie
maritime le tourisme la culture
l'économie numérique la recherche
l'économie sociale et solidaire
le redressement productif c'est d'abord
la volonté de rompre avec la
désindustrialisation quitte à l'heure un
plan de reconquête industrielle sera
prochainement présenté par le
gouvernement avec vos ambitions de
repositionner la france au meilleur
niveau mondial
un pays qui n'a pas d'industrie est un
pays qui n'a pas d'avenir en dix ans en
dix ans la part de l'industrie dans la
richesse produite en france a été divisé
par deux passant de 26% à 13 % et 750
mille emplois industriels ont été perdus
le gouvernement entend mettre un terme à
ce décrochage
c'est le sens du pacte national pour la
croissance la compétitivité l'emploi que
je vous propose
il sera au coeur de la conférence
sociale du mois de juillet les mesures
seront prises pour lutter contre les
plans sociaux abusif et rechercher des
solutions alternatives perret de la
compétitivité structurelle est l'une des
clés essentielles du redressement comme
dans d'autres pays européens
la spécialisation autour de créneaux
porteurs l'innovation la valorisation de
produits de qualité fonderont notre
stratégie industrielle nous avons des
atouts je veux donner à la france une
avance compétitive dans le domaine des
nouvelles technologies
faire émerger des champions nationaux
voire européen nous prendrons appuyé sur
le commissariat général à
l'investissement qui soutiendra des
projets d'excellence
au service de l'innovation et de
l'économie de demain la financera mise
au service de l'économie réelle
c'est pourquoi seront séparés les
activités des banques qui sont utiles à
l'investissement et à l'emploi de leurs
opérations spéculatives
il n'est pas acceptable que nos
entreprises et en particulier nos pme
continuent d'être confrontés à des
difficultés de financement la création
du livret épargne industrie permettra de
drainer les pins disponible à des fins
productives les activités génératrices
de croissance bénéficiant du soutien de
la banque publique d'investissement qui
sera mise en place avant la fin de
l'année et qui travaillera en liaison
avec les territoires les pme sur madame
nous avons noté que vous étiez présente
les pme seront l'objet d'un soutien
déterminé elle doit pouvoir profiter
pleinement des commandes publiques et
bénéficier de dispositifs fiscaux
avantageux
elles ne peuvent pas supporter les mêmes
taux d'imposition que les
multinationales leur croissance doit
être encouragée car c'est en se
développant davantage qu'elles font aux
tournées vers l'exportation et conquérir
de nouvelles parts de marché nous
offrirons à nouveau à nos agriculteurs
un projet d'avenir dans le cadre d'une
politique agricole commune qui sera
consolidée et rénové au niveau européen
les exigences croissantes en faveur de
la qualité des produits et de modes de
production plus respectueux de
l'environnement sont une chance pour nos
agriculteurs et nos professionnels de
l'agroalimentaire nous stimulerons à
travers une loi cadre le développement
d'une agriculture diversifiée durable et
performante
nous devons faire preuve d'une nouvelle
ambition pour notre commerce extérieur
les plus de 70
milliards d'euros de déficit en 2011
après dix années de dégradation de notre
compétitivité externe sont le résultat
du laisser-aller et du laisser faire
c'est le contraire de l'état d'esprit
qui animera le gouvernement une
véritable diplomatie économique sera
mise en place
la chine ou d'autres pays émergents
conserveront durablement une
compétitivité lié un coup de travail
très faible avec laquelle nous ne
pourrons pas et nous ne voulons pas à
rivaliser pour préserver les emplois nos
travailleurs et nos capacités de
production
nous avons nous européens le droit de
nous protéger de pratiques commerciales
déloyales exiger le respect de normes
sociales ou environnementales et la
réciprocité d'accès au marché
c'est le principe du juste échange que
nous voulons promouvoir la croissance et
la compétitivité que nous voulons
conforter doivent être au service de
l'emploi je veux affirmer devant le
parlement que le gouvernement mènera la
bataille de l'emploi comme un impératif
de chaque instant la lutte contre le
chômage bénéficiera du retour à une
politique économique volontariste elle
reposera aussi sur le renforcement des
moyens mis à disposition de pôle emploi
dont le rôle doit être confortée et
soutenu pour assurer un soutien
personnalisé à chaque demandeur d'emploi
dès cet été
2001 jean supplémentaires seront
recrutés et contribueront à accroître
les capacités d'intervention de pôle
emploi
pour les travailleurs les moins
qualifiés la maîtrise du coût du travail
reste un enjeu essentiel mais le
gouvernement ne sacrifiera pas le
pouvoir d'achat les français notamment
des plus modestes qui subissent de plein
fouet la hausse du coût du logement de
l'énergie et des transports
la conférence sociale se penchera sur la
question des bas salaires de la
progressivité des grilles salariales et
de la progression des carrières
elle traitera aussi des modalités de
financement de la protection sociale la
politique de redressement productif ne
peut pas être conduite par la france
seule notre continent est la première
puissance économique mondiale
les divisions les égoïsmes les
concurrences or autant de brèches à nos
concurrents sur le plan commercial
économique et diplomatique
l'europe est une puissance fragmenté
c'est cette solidarité imparfaite qui
soumet chacun nos pays et la cupidité
des spéculateurs
jusqu'ici l'europe est souvent intervenu
trop peu et trop tard
donnant le sentiment de n'être indre que
les flammes de la crise sans étouffer
ces braises je ne me résous pas à ce
constat c'est parce que l'europe donne
le sentiment de ne pas protéger les
peuples avec suffisamment de force que
le doute à pénétrer jusqu'aux esprit des
plus convaincus et je les comprends le
choix initial initiale des dirigeants
européens de généraliser l'autorité sans
ouvrir des perspectives de croissance a
renforcé le doute
l'heure est donc venue de réorienter le
projet européen
il n'y a pas une europe qui s'impose la
touche l'europe est ce que nous en
faisons retrouvons donc l'audace des
fondateurs l'union a donné la paix à
notre continent depuis plus de six
décennies ce qui a été fait pour la paix
doit l'être maintenant pour la
prospérité de ses 510 millions
d'habitants depuis le 6 mai dernier
l'élection du prix dans la république
française a fait bouger les lignes
le conseil européen vient d'adopter un
pacte de croissance d'un montant de 120
milliards d'euros la banque centrale
européenne supervisera dès la fin de
l'année
les banques de la zone euro l'union
bancaire est en marche le mécanisme
européen de stabilité pour à
recapitaliser directement les banques en
difficulté la maîtrise de la finance a
fait un pas en avant avec la mise en
place prochaine de la taxe sur les
transactions financières que nous avons
appelée si longtemps de nos voeux le
conseil européen des 28 et 29 juin après
18 autres sommets de crise a constitué
un tournant très positif le vote des
français à peser une étape a été
franchie celle de l'intégration
solidaire c'est pourquoi je demanderai
au parlement de se prononcer sur
l'ensemble des textes issus de cette
renégociation le pacte de croissance
la taxe sur les transactions financières
la supervision bancaire et le traité de
stabilité budgétaire
les nations les nations ne disparaîtront
pas il n'y aura pas de dilution de notre
identité mais nous savons aussi que dans
un contexte de mondialisation
notre avenir est indissociablement lié à
celui de nos voisins avec lesquels nous
partageons une culture et un modèle
social la relation franco allemande
occupe à cet égard une place centrale
vous connaissez ma conviction
personnelle sur cette relation qui
demeure le socle de la construction
européenne l'histoire nous a donné une
responsabilité particulière
ouvert aux autres pays de l'union qui
demandent légitimement leur part
d'initiative dans la décision
nos deux pays permettront à l'europe de
progresser chaque fois que la seule
d'arrêter avance l'intégration politique
devient possible
voilà mesdames et messieurs les
parlementaires
résumé en quelques mots les voix et les
outils qui nous permettront de retrouver
des marges de manoeuvre et d'assurer le
redressement dans la justice mais notre
ambition est plus vaste
le président de la république a fait de
la jeunesse et de l'éducation la
priorité de son quinquennat
c'est donc en pensant à l'avenir de la
jeunesse que sera conduite l'action du
gouvernement
l'école est au coeur de la promesse
république
c'est l'école qui fait naître parmi les
jeunes générations un profond sentiment
d'attachement à nos valeurs
fondamentales à la laïcité au civisme et
au respect des autres c'est l'école qui
permet la promotion sociale la
construction et l'affirmation d'une
citoyenneté libre fondée sur des droits
et des devoirs mais le constat est sans
appel
notre système éducatif le produit ses
effets que pour 80 % des jeunes et n'est
pas adapté pour les 20% restants l'échec
scolaire est encore massif les
inégalités sociales et territoriales
mines le contrat entre la nation et sur
l'école nous devons concentrer notre
attention et nos efforts sur
l'enseignement primaire et les premiers
cycles de l'enseignement supérieur qui
forment les maillons faibles de notre
système
c'est dans les première année que se
construit la réussite des élèves
l'objectif est de se reculer massivement
au cours de la mandature
le nombre de jeunes qui sortent du
système scolaire sans aucune
qualification pour servir cette ambition
je vous propose un nouveau contrat
éducatif 1000 professeurs des écoles
supplémentaires ont été recrutés dans
l'urgence pour faire face aux situations
les plus tendues dès la rentrée 2012
sur l'ensemble du quinquennat 60000
postes seront créés au terme de larges
concertations nous redéfiniront dans
l'intérêt des enfants les rythmes
scolaires
nous favoriserons la diversité des
parcours et les innovations pédagogiques
nous donneront un nouvel élan à
l'éducation prioritaire nous
mobiliserons l'ensemble des personnels
qui concourent au service public de
l'éducation est d'abord les professeurs
enseigner plus qu'un métier c'est une
vocation
il dépasse souvent l'engagement
professionnel la formation initiale des
professeurs sera rétabli et des écoles
supérieures du professorat et de
l'éducation seront instituées au sein
des universités le gouvernement
réformera la loi sur les universités
pour garantir le bon fonctionnement et
l'autonomie ray
les établissements d'enseignement
supérieur l'enseignement président
l'engagement présidentiel de créer une
allocation d'études et de formation sous
conditions de ressources sera mise en
oeuvre et 2 augmenteront le nombre de
logements étudiants
nous redonnons toute sa place à la
recherche à l'ère dassault sida
connaissance le rôle de la science et de
la recherche fondamentale doit être
réaffirmé il nous faudra renforcer les
liens entre universités et grandes
écoles laboratoires de recherche et
entreprises pour que les études
supérieures débouche véritablement sur
une association professionnelle et
concourent à la réussite du redressement
productif
je les dis la jeunesse est notre
priorité c'est le sens du pacte
générationnel associant l'insertion des
jeunes et le maintien des seniors dans
l'emploi c'est le sens du contrat de
génération
voulue par le président de la république
le gouvernement engagera la création
cent cinquante mille emplois d'avenir
qui seront proposés prioritairement à
des jeunes sans qualification en
particulier dans les quartiers où le
taux de chômage est le plus élevé le
développera également le service civique
cet égard je sais pouvoir compter sur le
mouvement olympique et sportif et sur
les milliers d'associations d'éducation
populaire pour faciliter ce passage à la
vie active qui est aussi le moment de
laisser nancy passion nous mettrons en
place un système de caution solidaire
qui offrira jeunes locataires la
possibilité de gagner leur pleine
autonomie en accédant au logement
au delà des aspirations de la jeunesse
transition est de permettre à chacun de
nos concitoyens à chaque ménage de cette
famille d'accéder à un logement
correspondant à ses besoins à son
pouvoir d'achat
le logement est en effet le premier
poste et dépend des français les ménages
modestes ont été particuliers pénalisé
par la flambée des prix au cours des
dernières années de trop nombreuses
familles ont dû quitter les centres
urbains le trop nombreux salariés ont
été contraints de se loger de plus en
plus loin de leur lieu de travail pour
répondre aux besoins des manuels de 500
mille logements dont 150 mille logements
sociaux sont mis en oeuvre un plan de
mobilisation du foncier sans précédent
sera lancée les terrains vacants de
l'état seront mis à disposition
gratuitement pour permettre la
réalisation
programme de construction et
d'aménagement urbain respectueux de la
mixité sociale
le plafond du livret à qui permet
notamment de financer le logement social
sera relevé en fonction des besoins le
gouvernement renforcera la loi relative
le gouvernement renforcera la loi
relative à la solidarité et au
renouvellement urbains les communes qui
ne respectent pas leurs obligations en
matière de logement social verront leurs
pénalités multiplié par cinq
sur le marché privé le gouvernement
prendra avant la fin du mois de juillet
des mesures en faveur de l'encadrement
des loyers dans les villes où les
tensions sont les plus fortes
conformément aux engagements pris en
faveur du développement durable et pour
limiter les dépenses des familles un
plan ambitieux de performances
techniques de leur habitat sera engagée
pour les logements neufs comme pour le
parc ancien on le voit à travers cet
exemple la transition écologique et
énergétique que le gouvernement veut
initier sera créatrice d'emplois
nouveaux nous voulons et nous allons
développer une économie verte fondée sur
l'innovation technologique qui sera
l'une des composantes de notre
redressement productif pour préserver
notre planète maîtriser nos
consommations de ressources naturelles
et diminuer notre empreinte écologique
nous construirons une société sobre et
efficace il en va de la protection de
l'environnement de la préservation de la
biodiversité et de l'indépendance
énergétique de la france
le code minier qui régit l'exploitation
notre sous sol sera réformé il imposera
les meilleures garanties de protection
de l'environnement et une parfaite
transparence dans l'instruction et la
délivrance des permis d'exploitation
nous engagerons un programme massif
d'économies d'énergie et un plan
ambitieux de développement des énergies
renouvelables la part du nucléaire dans
la production d'électricité passera à
l'horizon 2025 de 75% à 50% le gaz
d'électricité comme l'eau sont des biens
communs et ne peuvent pas être livré à
la seule loi du marché
nous mettrons en place une tarification
progressive avec un double objectif
social et écologique
l'état veillera prioritairement la
préservation à la modernisation des
infrastructures de transport
au service d'une mobilité plus sobre et
plus équitable et en lien avec les
collectivités locales
la réforme du système ferroviaire sera
engagée je crois profondément dans
l'alliance de l'état et des
collectivités locales pour mettre en
mouvement l'ensemble des acteurs de la
société
je crois à la nécessité d'un état
stratège garant de la cohérence des
politiques publiques et de la solidarité
entre les citoyens et les territoires
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
la décentralisation doit aller de pair
avec la réforme de l'état
nous procéderons là encore avec méthode
dans la concertation mais avec
détermination
j'ai souhaité que le rôle des services
publics et leurs agents soit inscrit au
coeur de la conférence sociale
nous réaffirmons leur place et leur
mission au service d'intérêt général et
la cohésion nationale le chantier de la
décentralisation est immense la loi
instituant le conseiller territorial
sera brrr le mode d'élection des
conseillers généraux sera modifié pour
permettre une meilleure représentativité
des assemblées départementales
je souhaite préparer de manière
concertée et transparente cette
modification du mode de scrutin ainsi
que celle du calendrier des élections
cantonales et régionales le parlement il
sera étroitement associés je recevrai ce
mois ci les associations d'élus je
poursuivrai les consultations la rentrée
et je m'appuierai sur les conclusions
des états généraux organisés par le
sénat afin que le gouvernement puisse
déposer un projet de loi avant la fin de
cette année les citoyens attendent de
cette nouvelle étape de la
décentralisation que l'état et les
collectivités locales mènent une action
plus lisible plus efficace et moins
coûteuse il faut en finir avec les
doublons administratifs les
collectivités prendront leur part de
l'effort national de redressement des
comptes avec davantage d'autonomie de
responsabilité dans le cadre d'un pacte
financier avec l'état mesdames et
messieurs les parlementaires notre
ambition est de promouvoir une
république rénover et de moderniser nos
institutions afin de conforter notre
démocratie tout en garantissant la
stabilité que permet le scrutin
majoritaire
une part de proportionnelle sera
introduite dans le mode de scrutin des
législatives pour la prochaine
législature le gouvernement proposera
l'ouverture de droits de vote pour les
élections municipales aux étrangers
résidant en situation régulière
depuis au moins 5 ans sur notre
territoire
nous présenterons un projet de loi sur
la moralisation de la vie politique pour
prévenir efficacement les conflits
d'intérêts et pour adapter les règles de
financement des partis politiques
pour permettre aux parlementaires de se
consacrer pleinement leur mission
il sera mis fin comme c'est déjà le cas
pour les membres du gouvernement au
cumul entre un mandat de parlementaire
et l'exercice de fonctions exécutives
locales
cette réforme sera applicable en 2014
avant la fin de l'année 2000 touche une
loi relative à l'audiovisuel
je vois que ça vous fait plaisir avant
la fin de l'année 2012 une loi relative
à l'audiovisuel permettra de restaurer
les grands principes républicains
quant aux modalités de désignation des
présidents de l'audiovisuel public dans
le cadre d'un conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel rénové et la protection
des sources des journalistes sera
renforcé certaines de ses réformes qui
en bon ambition de faire progresser
notre démocratie nécessiteront une
révision de la constitution
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
certains services de l'état ont été
considérablement affaiblie avec un effet
particulièrement désastreux dans la
police et la gendarmerie
alors que les attentes des français en
matière de sécurité n'ont jamais été
aussi forte
la montée de la violence appelle une
réponse ferme de la puissance publique
notre préoccupation sera celle de
l'efficacité
les lois se sont ajoutés aux lois un
activisme brouillon a prévalu depuis une
dizaine d'années les opérations coup de
poing se sont succédé mais sans grand
effet sur les questions de justice et de
sécurité
nous devons regagner en sérénité pour
retrouver le chemin de l'efficacité et
de la confiance
efficacité retrouvée de la politique
pénale tout d'abord avec des prisons
surpeuplées la réinsertion devient
impossible et la récidive plus
fréquentes avec 85 mille peines
d'emprisonnement prononcées mais non
exécutée cette politique pénale est un
échec
chaque infraction à la loi appelle une
sanction y compris pour les mineures
mais pour être efficace la peine doit
être tout juste adaptée et proportionnée
j'entends ouvrir le chantier ambitieux
de notre politique pénale pour que le
gouvernement puissent restaurer les
conditions de son efficacité efficacité
de l'action de la police efficacité
l'action de la gendarmerie ensuite
la politique du chiffre à détourner les
forces de sécurité d'une action menée en
profondeur l'ordre public se construit
pourtant dans la durée il n'est pas
compatible avec la culture de l'instant
il est le résultat d'un travail patient
déterminer le fruit de l'engagement
quotidien des hommes et des femmes qui
ont la confiance et qui concourent
chaque jour et chaque nuit à la sécurité
de nos concitoyens
dès la constitution du gouvernement
j'ai demandé que s'instaure un dialogue
de qualité entre la justice la police et
la gendarmerie des travaux conjoints ont
commencé ils déboucheront sur de
nouvelles instructions commune dans la
lutte contre toutes les formes de
délinquance des incivilités au trafic et
aux bandes
rien ne sera tolérée mais tout sera
engagée depuis la prévention jusqu'à la
répression nous inverserons la baisse
des effectifs dans les services publics
de la sécurité intérieure de la justice
avec la création chaque année des 1000
postes supplémentaires sur lesquels
s'est engagé monsieur le président de la
république et nous créerons des zones de
sécurité prioritaire au plus près des
réalités de terrain
j'ai par expérience la conviction le
maire a un rôle essentiel à jouer un
service cet objectif d'efficacité
connaît les aspirations profondes de ses
administrés il peut mobiliser des
acteurs le coup au service de la lutte
contre la délinquance et la sécurité il
promet sa part dans la restauration de
la confiance entre les citoyens et les
services de police et de gendarmerie
nous devons également restaurer la
confiance dans l'institution judiciaire
cela passe par la réaffirmation de son
indépendance
un principe fondamental sur lequel ce
gouvernement ne transigera pas elle sera
garantie par la réforme du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature qui
interviendra en 2013
je redis ma conscience dans les
magistrats et les fonctionnaires de la
justice
une circulaire abolissant les
instructions individuelles ou parqués
sur à signer avant la fin de ce mois les
français se méfient parfois du système
judiciaire qu'il redoute autant qu'il le
respecte
nous demande simplifier nos structures
et nos procédures judiciaires de faire
progresser les droits des victimes nous
le serons l'un bien messieurs les
parlementaires au coeur du pacte
républicain la solidarité est une valeur
forte qui contribue à la cohésion
sociale et l'état en est le garant
conférence sociale ouvrira une
concertation sur les retraites afin
d'assurer la pérennité de notre système
par répartition en prenant en compte
l'allongement de l'espérance de vie mais
aussi la pénibilité du travail accompli
sans attendre le gouvernement a pris une
mesure de justice sociale la possibilité
de prendre sa retraite à 60 ans à taux
plein pour celles et ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler très jeune et qui
ont acquis les annuités nécessaires
c'est également au nom de la justice
sociale et la solidarité à l'égard des
familles modestes
l'om a décidé d'augmenter de 25%
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire
notre système de santé est aujourd'hui
mise à mal par l'augmentation des restes
à charge qui pèse sur les français les
plus modestes par les inégalités de
santé ce qui se creusent et par les
déserts médicaux
les dépassements d'horaires qui privent
d'accès aux soins une partie de la
population
il est également miné par les déficits
il attend face à la petite aux grands
enjeux de santé d'aujourd'hui le
vieillissement de la population le
développement des maladies chroniques
les addictions nous devons donc rebâtir
un système de santé qui soit
véritablement accessible et performant
cette réforme s'inscrira dans une
stratégie nationale de santé il s'agira
de refonder l'organisation du système de
soins pour permettre une meilleure
coopération entre les professionnels de
santé conforter les soins de premier
recours et reconnaître l'hôpital dans
ces véritables missions nous aurons une
attention particulière pour nos
concitoyens les plus fragiles ils
doivent avoir toute leur place dans la
société il nous faut rendre accessible
le mans du travail l'ensemble des
services en particulier aux personnes en
situation de handicap en prenant en
compte les différents types de handicaps
accès aux bâtiments aux transports à
l'emploi axial écoles avec dès la
rentrée 2012
le recrutement de 1500 auxiliaire de
vie scolaire individuelle là la tension
et la place réservée aux personnes âgées
dépendantes
j'ai entendu un encore je suggère que
celui qui par rapport à au recrutement
de cash sans auxiliaire de vie scolaire
individuelle à y défendre cette encore
devant les personnes concernées et leurs
parents
la tension et la place réservée aux
personnes âgées dépendantes est une
question de dignité
la tension et la place
la tension
ça venait
madame madame permettez moi de vous dire
le sénat est cité souvent pour sa
courtoisie et le respect des autres
je vous demande d'avoir la gentillesse
de vous en souvenir cet après midi la
tension et la place les services aux
personnes âgées dépendantes est une
question
est une question de dignité et
d'humanité malgré ses promesses le
gouvernement précédent n'a pas engagé la
réforme de la dépendance qu'il avait
annoncé une réforme juste et solidaire
de la prise en charge des personnes
âgées privées d'autonomie sera engagée
enfin je n'oublie pas ceux de nos
concitoyens
une famille sur sept qui vivent dans une
grande précarité
l'élaboration d'un plan de lutte contre
la pauvreté sont engagés sans retard
j'organiserai une grande confiance à
l'automne avec les associations les
collectivités locales les organismes de
protection sociale qui sont au coeur de
la lutte contre la pauvreté
notre société évolue les modes de vie
les mentalités changent les aspirations
nouvelles s'affirme le gouvernement y
répondra au nom du principe d'égalité au
premier semestre 2013 de droit au
mariage et à l'adoption sont ouverts à
tous les couples sans discrimination de
même le temps est venu de donner à
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
la force de l'évidence
nulle part sur le territoire de la
république
nous ne tolérerons - le moindre écart
par rapport à ce principe fondamental
pour prendre l'exemple de l'assemblée
nationale elle compte 27 % de femmes
c'est un progrès mais nous sommes loin
de la parité la réforme à venir des
règles de financement des partis
politiques pourraient contribuer
efficacement à cet objectif
c'est aussi au sein de l'entreprise que
nous voulons bousculer ces inégalités
choquant
le combat pour l'égalité professionnelle
et l'égalité salariale entre les femmes
et les hommes sera menée avec
détermination par le gouvernement
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
la réplique française est une terre
d'immigration et d'intégration sur ce
sujet trop de patients divisent nos
compatriotes
l'entendant faire prévaloir une approche
sobre et digne du débat dans un esprit
de responsabilité et avec le souci
constant du respect des valeurs de la
république dans chaque pays démocratique
il y a des règles relatives à l'entrée
au séjour des étrangers l'immigration
économique fera chaque année l'objet
d'un débat au parlement
la lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière et contre les filières du
travail clandestin sera menée avec
fermeté le droit s'appliquera pour les
reconduites à la frontière des
régularisations pourront être autorisés
après un examen individuel en fonction
de critères précis objectifs et qui
seront appliquées uniformément sur
l'ensemble du territoire mais aucun
enfant aucune famille ne sera placé dans
un centre de rétention le droit d'asile
est un droit sacré même s'il ne doit pas
être détourné les demandeurs d'asile
recevront une réponse dans des délais
qui seront raccourcis les étudiants
étrangers pourront s'engager dans une
première expérience professionnelle en
france après la fin de leurs études
c'est le sens de la circulaire qui a été
adoptée le 31 mai dernier pour les
étrangers qui vivent en situation
régulière sur notre sol les titres de
séjour seront sécurisés les étrangers
qui aspirent à ville durablement dans
notre pays doivent accepter les droits
et les devoirs qui lui sont associées et
doivent prendre leur part de l'effort
d'intégration mais ils doivent aussi
pouvoir accéder à la nationalité
française
lorsque après plusieurs années sur notre
territoire
ils manifestent solennellement leur
désir d'être français qu'ils respectent
scrupuleusement nos valeurs et notamment
celle de la laïcité
la procédure de naturalisation ainsi que
des règles claires seront redéfinis pour
rendre cet accès possible mesdames et
messieurs les parlementaires et ne peut
pas y avoir de redressement sans projet
culturel le gouvernement soutiendra la
création et la diffusion sur tout le
territoire en rien avec les
collectivités locales dont je tiens à
saluer l'engagement souvent exemplaire
je proposerai au parlement au cours du
premier semestre 2013
une loi d'orientation sur la création et
sur le spectacle vivant en septembre
2012 seront présentés les orientations
du grand plan d'éducation arty
stick et culturels une mission sur
l'acte 2 de l'exception culturelle
française qui considère à la défense des
droits des créateurs et un accès aux
offres par internet facilite et sécurise
et a été lancée débouchera sur un
nouveau cadre juridique au cours du
premier semestre 2013
face aux grands enjeux internationaux
la france jouera pleinement son rôle et
tiendra le langage que le monde a appris
à aimer d'elle mesdames et messieurs les
parlementaires
la france n'est écoutés et respectés que
quand elle est fidèle à elle même
respect des droits de l'homme justice
solidarité à l'égard des pays en
développement dialogue avec les pays
émergents force de notre conviction
européenne et notre engagement
multilatéral et bien sûr soutien à
celles et ceux qui luttent pour la
démocratie partout dans le monde
telles sont les pierres angulaires de
notre politique étrangère dans les pays
de la rive sud de la méditerranée
nous accompagnerons les peuples dans
leur cheminement vers la démocratie il
est urgent de mettre fin à la spirale de
la répression et de la violence en syrie
en mobilisant la communauté
internationale en faveur d'une
transition politique qui passe par le
départ de bachar el assad
la france est pleinement engagée pour
atteindre cet objectif en afrique la
construction d'états démocratiques a
tout notre soutien
une rupture avec les dérives de la
françafrique est attendu dans un
continent dont les perspectives de
croissance sont porteuses d'espoir nous
nous attacherons à développer avec les
pays qui le souhaitent un partenariat
d'égal à égal
reposant sur la bonne gouvernance le
développement et la mobilisation de
toutes les énergies
la destruction de plusieurs mausolées à
tombouctou rappelle que nous sommes
confrontés aux forces obscurantistes et
plus rétrogrades notre détermination
sera totale pour empêcher aqmi de
constituer au nord-mali des bastions du
terrorisme ati
nationale qui menace la paix et la
prospérité de l'ensemble de la région
comme notre propre sécurité
nous sommes également déterminés à
empêcher la fuite en avant du programme
nucléaire iranien par la fermeté et donc
par des sanctions tout en préservant la
voie du dialogue en matière de défense
le gouvernement mettra en oeuvre les
engagements du président de la
république chef des armées
le retrait d'afghanistan des forces
françaises combattantes sera effectif à
la fin de cette année pour préparer
l'avenir
un livre blanc de la défense et de la
sécurité nationale sera élaboré pour la
fin de l'année 2012 est présenté au
parlement au début de l'année 2013
une loi de programmation militaire
suivra les choix qui s'imposent se
feront dans la transparence et la
cohérence au terme d'un débat ouvert et
démocratique
ces choix assureront les conditions de
notre indépendance notre force de
dissuasion nucléaire garantie
essentielle de notre sécurité sera
maintenue nous l'engagerons résolument
en faveur de l'europe de la défense qui
doit prendre une dimension nouvelle
fidèle à nos alliances nous devrons
évaluer les conditions dans lesquelles
notre pays a rejoint le commandement
intégré de l'otan
je veux saluer devant vous les femmes et
les hommes militaires et civils qui sont
engagés dans la défense de notre pays
notre compassion va à nos soldats morts
ou blessés en opération au 87 soldats
morts pour la france en afghanistan ou
familles des soldats tués aux blessés
qui restent meurtries dans leur chair
je veux dire ici que nous avons le
devoir de les accompagner et que nous ne
les oublierons pas
elham les messieurs les parlementaires
tout au long de cette intervention
c'est monsieur le premier ministre qui
s'expriment j'ai pensé à ces femmes et à
ces hommes que j'ai rencontrés ces
dernières semaines dans le train ou dans
les rues à travers toutes les régions de
france
souvent lu dans leurs yeux autant
d'espoirs que d'inquiétudes
la crainte est appelé à de nouveaux
sacrifices alors qu'ils ont le sentiment
d'avoir déjà produit tant d'efforts 4
que le dessin la france ne se joue déjà
plus sur son sol
la crainte que derrière les promesses se
prépare des désillusions nouvelles
chaque fois j'ai pris un engagement dans
te et c'est cet engagement que je veux
réitérer devant situation de notre pays
comme celles de l'europe est
préoccupante
le redressement prendra du temps ce sera
difficile mais nous réussirons
j'ai confiance dans nos atouts j'ai
confiance dans ce que nous sommes
le gouvernement travaillera sous
l'autorité du premier ministre et sa
responsabilité dans la transparence et
la clarté
rien ne sera caché des difficultés
auxquels nous serons confrontés
nous n'éluderons pas les problèmes nous
les affronterons l'un après l'autre
nous mettrons tout en oeuvre pour que la
démocratie retrouve sa pleine
souveraineté vis-à-vis des marchés
financiers nous ferons en sorte que
chaque décision soit empreinte du sceau
de la justice des obstacles se
dresseront sur notre route
certaines bonnes âmes nous inviterons
sans doute renoncement d'autres nous
inciteront à la résignation
alors c'est vers vous que nous nous
retournerons essai sur votre force que
le premier mis sa pure à la france est
un vieux pays d'un vieux continent mais
c'est aussi un pays neuf moderne la
créativité attaque il y a tellement
d'énergie qu'ils ne demandent qu'à être
libéré tellement de talent dans nos
villes dans le campagne dans nos
quartiers tellement d'idées qui
attendent de s'exprimer voilà ce qui
nous rend confiants labs et messieurs
les parlementaires nous avons reçu la
france en héritage nous sommes fiers de
son modèle qui porte le si beau nom de
république sur le fronton de nos écoles
et nos édifices publics sont inscrits
nos valeurs elles ont permis à des
femmes et des hommes de toutes origines
de toutes conditions de toute religion
de toute philosophie de vivre ensemble
comme probablement nulle part ailleurs
elles ont permis d'élever des
générations vers une vie meilleure
la france c'est plus qu'une histoire
c'est une idée de la condition humaine
c'est cette dimension qu aucun marché ne
prendra jamais en compte ce sont ces
valeurs qui ne sont pas cotées mais qui
pour nous n'ont pas de prix aucune
agence notre à jamais notre rêve parce
qu'il ne relève que de votre confiance
et de celle des français
merci
merci merci monsieur le ministre acte
est donnée de la déclaration de
politique générale dont il vient d'être
donné lecture au sénat je vais tout
d'abord maintenant vous donner lecture
des conclusions de la conférence des
présidents qui s'est réuni le 28 juin
dernier
cette conférence à fixer l'ordre du jour
jusqu'au mardi 31 juillet 2012
demain mercredi 4 juillet à 15 heures
déclaration du gouvernement suivie d'un
débat en application de l'article 50-1
de la constitution jeudi 5 juillet à 15
heures débat sur les résultats du
conseil européen des 28 et 29 juin
mardi 10 juillet à 14h30 proposition de
loi visant à abroger la loi relative à
la majoration des droits à construire
mercredi en juillet à 14h30 et le soir
projet de loi relatif au harcèlement
sexuel jeudi 12 juillet à 9h30 débat sur
la politique commune de la pêche à 15
heures après les questions d'actualité
au gouvernement
éventuellement suite de l'ordre du jour
du matin mardi 17 juillet à 14h30 et le
soir le matin est à réserver aux
questions orales
sous réserve de sa transmission projet
de loi de règlement des comptes et
rapport de gestion pour l'année 2011
débat sur les orientations des finances
publiques
mercredi 18 juillet à 14h30
neuf conventions internationales dont 2
examiné selon la forme simplifiée
non voilà nous interrompons à cette
séance vous l'avez vu particulièrement
agitée c'est peut-être un signe que jean
marc ayrault
cet après midi n'aura pas la partie
facile devant les sénateurs
sans plus tarder à nous prenons à la
direction de la salle clemenceau pour
suivre en direct l'audition de didier
migaud le président de la cour des
comptes est entendu par les sénateurs de
la commission des finances
deux jours après la remise de son
rapport au premier ministre
la cour des comptes qui estime que
l'état va devoir réaliser 40 milliards
d'euros d'économies pour maintenir et
bien ses prévisions de réduction du
déficit d'ici à l'an prochain
bonne audition